we may have solved one of the biggest
dissonant mysteries yet we've got some
pretty compelling theories about
Audrey's whereabouts during dissonance -
here's a hint it has everything to do
with her new transformation in
descendants three watch until the end to
find out what Audrey's master plan is
and if she cooked it up alone what's the
harm it's deeply Magic the
sherwoodforest many fans noticed that
Audrey didn't appear in the second
descendants movie despite having been
mentioned many times while she was not
physically present she did call Chad
charming right before the cotillion the
scene starts with Chad taking some
liberties with the 3d printer in
Carlos's room he prints a fake crown and
puts it on his head then he looks in the
mirror and pretends he is talking to
Audrey he says that he hasn't chosen a
queen yet then his phone rings Chad
completely freaks out when he sees that
it's Audrey calling Carlos walks in and
catches Chad in the act of impersonating
a king with the fake crown while
scrambling to answer his phone on the
other end of the phone Audrey tells Chad
that she got a flat tire in the Sherwood
Forest and she wants him to come fix it
apparently the forest is pretty far away
six hours to be exact
Chad jumps at the chance to rescue his
fair lady but not before Carlos takes
away his phony crown so what was odd to
be doing in Sherwood Forest Disney's
Robin Hood fans know that the Sherwood
Forest is the place where Robin Hood and
Little John live it is located in
westerly which is one of the eighteen
regions of auradon
in the novel returns to the Isle of the
Lost one of King Arthur's guards talks
about a mysterious creature who nearly
burned down the Sherwood Forest could
that mysterious creature have been a
dragon
maybe Maleficent was causing trouble in
the Sherwood Forest long before Audrey
got there so back to Audrey's trip to
the Sherwood Forest we know that
everyone believed that Audrey went on a
spa vacation with flora fauna and
Merryweather or the fairies that helped
Audrey's mother in Disney's Sleeping
Beauty Ardoin off to a spa vacation with
flora fauna and Merryweather but did she
really go on a trip with the fairies to
get facials and massages or was that a
cover for the real reason she was in the
Sherwood Forest if Audrey had the help
of the fairies why would she need to
call Chad charming to rescue her when
she got a flat tire maybe she was trying
to lure Chad out there for some other
reason
and maybe she made another stop before
she headed to the forest to do her
damsel-in-distress
routine that brings us to descendents
three Audrey's transformation by now
every descendents fan has probably seen
the picture of Audrey with her new look
she's rocking pink hair and a distressed
pink leather outfit in the pictures
Audrey is holding Maleficent staff and
she's also wearing the crown from the
Museum of cultural history this wicked
transformation has got everyone in The
Descendants fan verse talking while we
are not sure about the details
surrounding her transformation we've got
some pretty good ideas about where she
went during the course of descendants -
and it's not just the sherwoodforest
Audrey may have made a few stops on her
way to becoming evil the first stop
wasn't the spa and Sherwood Forest the
first stop was to see someone who Audrey
shares a common enemy with but who could
this person be the aisle one theory is
that Audrey visited the aisle before
heading to the Sherwood Forest to meet
with a certain tentacled villian kid
both Audrey and uma have a common enemy
they both want to overthrow mal and take
what they believe is rightfully theirs
for uma that means taking over Arden and
destroying the barrier that keeps the
villains on the Isle without the use of
their magical powers audrey has a major
score to settle with mal now as mom did
curse Audrey's mom the fact that Audrey
was quick to point out when they first
met in descendants I totally do not
blame you for your mother trying to kill
my parents and stuff she had literally
just stepped foot on to auradon when
Audrey brought up their unfortunate
history in addition to their dark past
Mouse though Audrey's love interest she
cast a love spell on Ben turning his
attention to her instead of Audrey on
top of that malice on the line to take
the crown with Ben and Audrey once that
crown of more than anything so woman
Audrey have a lot of reasons to come
together and destroy their common enemy
Audrey may have gone to the Isle to
hatch an evil plan and Audrey's new look
could be from a visit to dizzy salon but
we don't think dizzy was involved in the
evil plot she loves mal too much to do
anything to hurt her then after Audrey
Animas meeting Audrey could have agreed
to steal Maleficent scepter from the
museum and use it to take down the
barrier so that uma and the other
villains could be free but then when
Audrey got to the museum and saw
crown she decided she had to have it so
she took that as well
then for some unknown reason Audrey went
to the Sherwood Forest with the crown
and scepter she lured Chad out there to
help her carry out whatever nefarious
plot she cooked up from the trailers and
pictures it looks like Audrey is in the
forests with the sceptre we've seen the
shots of Chad next to audrey looking
scared out of his mind but what is he
afraid of hades in the very first
descendants three trailer mal is walking
through a forest she walks up to that
glowing blue orb it's whispering her
name she thinks it sounds like her dad
dad when she goes to touch it the blue
flame flares up and startles her so is
this the spirit of Hades we're not sure
yet if Hades is good or evil but for
this theory let's assume he is up to no
good it makes sense that after Audrey
met with uma and stole the sector she
would go to the forest and find Hades
maybe she is planning to use the sector
to somehow free Hades from the glowing
orb he must have a major part to play an
Audrey and Houmas plan if they free
Hades maybe he can help them take over
our dime the mystery trailer says that
Hades ember is even more powerful than
maleficent scepter so maybe Audrey
enlists the help of Hades and his blue
Ember somehow we see in the trailer that
uma is holding the blue ember maybe
Audrey and uma still the Ember from
Hades we thought that it was Hades who
drain smells magic with the Ember but
maybe it's actually uma mal is going to
have to face some formidable opponents
in d3
we're pretty sure audrey is one of those
opponents Celia possibly ur youtuber
Alice bunny believes that Celia fassl
beer has a major hand in turning Audrey
evil she believes that Celia used
Audrey's anger and fear to turn her into
a wicked villain with the help of
Maleficent sceptre in previous trailers
Celia seems like she is helping now but
in the mystery trailer Celia has a
menacing look on her face and an evil
laugh to go with it Alice bunny points
to the scene in which Celia is in the
back of the room holding dude the dog
while the armored guards take their
fighting stance those are the same
guards who are fighting mal uma and
their crews so - Celia command these
guards
Celia also has her own shadow cards
similar to those which were used by her
dad dr. fasoli heir to get power over
others by
nipple ating their weaknesses it's
possible that Celia is just like her
father and is controlling everyone with
voodoo magic we've mentioned before that
it is possible that Celia is pretending
to be mouths friend but she is really
trying to trick her maybe the same was
true with Audrey it's likely that Celia
was able to use the shadow cards to show
Audrey who she really wants to be who
was the person she is most jealous of
mal of course
so Celia turns Audrey evil so she will
do her bidding fans believe that Audrey
will be the victim of the sleep spell
that knocks everyone else within the
kingdom when Celia and her dad use
Audrey they will put her to sleep and
take over Arden maybe Queen Leah made a
deal with Hades to get Audrey back so
that's why we see him looming over her
bed waving the blue Ember that would
mean that the villain kids will have to
team up to stop Celia and dr. facile ear
this would make for an epic battle it's
hard to tell if Emma and her crew are on
the outside or just tolerating her so
they can fight a common enemy it seems
highly unlikely that uma would suddenly
be friends with mal considering their
history but if the enemy is powerful
enough they may have no choice but to
put their differences aside to save our
don and the people on the isle mental
breakdown after all the crazy stuff that
happened in the first descendants movie
it's quite possible Audrey had a mental
breakdown she was under a lot of stress
dealing with Maleficent's daughter being
at her school remember that scene at
family day Audrey's grandmother meets Al
and for a second she believes that now
is actually Maleficent and that she
hasn't aged I'm how have you stayed so
young when Queen Leah discovers that
she's Maleficent's daughter she doesn't
take it very well things get way out of
hand queen leah is very upset then Chad
steps in and accuses mal and her friends
of being evil
he calls mal a boyfriend stealer he then
called Evie a gold digger and a cheater
Evie takes out her mirror and says the
phrase Mirror Mirror in my hand who's
the biggest jerk in the land then she
holds out the mirror to display Chad's
reflection chad tries to take the mirror
and jay steps in to fight him off things
escalate quickly so Evie pulls out her
magic sleep potion and sprays Chad in
the face making him fall asleep this
must have been super triggering for
Audrey and her grandmother given their
family history of being
swift sleep spells if you think about it
Audrey wouldn't have existed at all
if Maleficent had it her way and while
Audrey is seen in the final dance number
smiling and dancing with Jay it may have
been too much for her to handle could
Audrey's transformation be the result of
a mental breakdown that made her turn
evil that cottage Audrey stands in front
of in the trailer could be a mental
health facility Celebrity Rehab centers
are usually in the forest or some other
quiet natural location this could have
pushed her grandmother Queen Lea over
the edge too which leads us to the next
piece of the puzzle
Queen Lea looking back on that encounter
between mal and Queen Lea it's clear
that there is still a lot of bad blood
between Audrey and mouths family at
first Queen Lea's having a lovely chat
with now before she knows who mal is
then Audrey comes out to tell her
grandmother that she shouldn't talk to
mal yes you feel like taking another
hundred-year nap at first Queen Lea is
confused
she thinks mal is Maleficent and has
found a way to stay young thin steps in
and tells Audrey's grandmother that
Maleficent is still on the Isle and that
she is actually talking to Mau
Maleficent's daughter then reminds
Graeme that he made a proclamation to
give the new generation of villain kids
a chance Queen Leah says he has given
the villain kids a chance to destroy
auradon she reminds everyone about the
poison apples and the spells she tells
mal that her daughter was raised by
fairies because of her mother's curse
she laments at how she never got to hear
Aurora's first words or see her walk for
the first time because of Maleficent
clearly Queen Leah still has some
healing to do when you Harbor a grudge
like that for so long it eats away at
you it can turn you into a spiteful
person who only wants to get revenge so
it's possible that Audrey and her
grandmother teamed up to get even with
mal for her mother's crimes against
their family maybe queen leah is with
Audrey in the Sherwood Forest plotting
their revenge while we don't know for
sure yet where Audrey really was during
descendants - it's fun to imagine her
course on the path of evil what do you
think happened to Audrey if you think
she and her grandmother turned evil to
get revenge on mal leave a crown emoji
in the comments if you love descendants
theories as much as we do be sure to hit
that subscribe button and while you're
at it give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching the things we'll see
you soon
[Music]